there was drama okay this is check  Black's King is now hit by the white  Rook where's that King going well it  can't step onto the c-line  because then The Rook will swing over to  the Sea force zero oh he's gonna lose on  time over three seconds there's a small  delay here but and it's going to be over  now it's going to be a draw White's  Bishop can just take that pawn yeah  and the black Bishop is going to be  captured if the white Bishop Falls  finally there was a bit of drama but it  was always a draw and we're going to see  a result any moment play on boys another  hour 50 more moves the first king to get  to okay here you go King against King  153 moves and only the Kings left on the  board the final game on day one of the  aim chest rapid is a draw between  pentalari Krishna and vidit wow a long  fight we have to uh give them credit for  endurance these